Okay.
That was so cool. Thank you, Theresa.
Thanks for having me here. Thank you.
I just totally nerded out. So, so welcome.
Thank you for coming. Thank
you. It's lovely to be here. Um,
do you want to talk about
what you just played?
Oh yeah, sure. So the first
piece I played was very old.
It was by a German composer named
Bach. He had of many, many children,
so he was very prolific in
child making and music writing.
So that was probably one of his
most well known a cello pieces.
You guys probably have heard
it somewhere before, right?
Like Nike commercials and
basically anything with a
cello, it's like synonymous.
Oh, what's that? That's
the cello piece. Um,
and then after that I was actually the
main theme from the new wonder woman
series. Um, and I did do the
original with Hans Zimmer's, so
thank you. So, uh,
and it's very exciting that very soon
we're going to start working on wonder
woman to some music for that.
So I'm very excited about that.
And that was it.
Now I'm sitting here.
Thank you. Well, I am
a huge fan of Dina. Um,
I actually met her a couple of years ago.
I gave her my business card because
I was like, I need to meet you. Like,
it was a really creepy and stalkerish way.
Um, so I was like, Hey, let me interview.
Um, so, uh, so thank you for coming.
I actually seen her twice in concert.
[inaudible] she's amazing. So I wanted to
start with really background questions.
Like when did you start playing the cello?
What made you choose that particular
instrument? Was it Kinda like your choice?
What's it like forced upon you by your
parents? Like what, what was that?
Yes, so, uh, I was born in Shanghai,
China, so I was made in China. Um,
and my first instrument, like many,
many Chinese children was piano.
Uh, so I started when I was three years
old and then later I moved to the u s my
parents are actually
both classical musicians,
so there are classical music teachers
who live in San Diego and they,
so they popped me out and then they came
to us because they were able to, uh,
have an opportunity to go to school
in the u s for music at a scholarship.
And that was very, very rare. And like
post communist China like right after.
So they took the opportunity
and my grandparents,
my mom's parents actually raised me,
uh,
for a few years while they were here
studying. I got really, really large.
I weighed when I came to America.
I'm not kidding you.
I was like 82 pounds at five years
old. That is not normal. Right.
So I was like a little round ball. Oh,
I play the piano and then I moved here.
Uh,
and my parents thought that I should play
one of the instruments that they knew
how to play. Cause obviously that
would save money on music lessons.
So I started on the violin. I
was really bad. I played twinkle,
twinkle little star for, I'm again,
I'm not exaggerating like six months,
like I couldn't, I could not get past
twinkle, twinkle little star, like, well,
she's not talented. Right. So, um, then I
switched to the cello and for some reason,
even though it's like kind of similar, it
just came a lot more naturally. Um, and,
and I seem to like progress pretty
quickly. So my dad decided, okay,
this is what she's going to play.
And from there on out, I was,
I have to say forced to be honest,
I was forced to practice
eight hours a day every day,
which I'm grateful for now. Uh, I didn't
have much of a childhood, I have to admit.
And I was very, hence probably my love
for metal now. It was very like, oh,
I hate my life. And my
parents. I mean it was,
it was really extreme and
I've talked about it before,
so hopefully they'll forgive me
for like, you know, spilling the,
the family secrets.
But they would like lock me in my room
sometimes to practice and they're like,
let me out once in a while
ago. The bathroom, maybe eat
something if I was lucky.
Um, but I have to say that
type of like very regimented,
strict training.
Um,
really I have to say it did pay off in
the end cause like if you don't practice
for that many hours every day and we
know whether it's cello or swimming or
basketball, you don't build
that type of muscle memory.
So I was like more comfortable playing
the cello than really doing anything else.
Um, so yeah, to answer your question,
I was forced into the family trade,
but I'm happy to be here now.
I mean, yeah, that sounds that your,
your parents sound both terrifying,
but also thank you to your parents
for it. Yeah, yeah, yeah. No
slightly terrifying. But, but also
at the same time, I mean, I don't,
I think it actually takes a lot of,
uh,
a courage and a lot of determination
and sacrifice on their part. You know,
cause I, when I have babies, I
don't have kids yet, but I'm like,
I don't know if I can spend
that many hours. Like, you know,
like yelling at my kids practice
dedication. Yeah. Cool.
Um, so, uh, you know,
whether it was growing up or
now, you know, uh, what do
you think where, you know,
other than your parents,
uh, music influences that,
that kind of affected you or that inspire
you to like keep playing and, and, uh,
you know, whether it's this
instrument or, or other type of music.
Cause you mentioned metal as well.
Yeah, definitely. So, um, again,
growing up because my parents were
ultra conservative and just very, very,
you know, classical music is good.
Anything else? It's a music of the devil.
You can't listen to it. So
I actually, and of course,
what happens when you don't allow people
to do something, they get very curious,
especially me because I'm really a
contrarion in many ways where I'm like,
Oh yeah, I'm going to. Um, so,
so the very first exposure
that I had to like,
I guess heavier music or the underground
alternative was a Marilyn Manson.
And how did this come about? So I was in
awe. I was in seventh grade, I suppose,
a little bit later in life. I
mean, that's not that late in life,
but seventh grade. Um, and I,
I remember I had this
crush on a kid named Luke.
He was like a combination of a goth and
a nerd. He was like a Nerdy Goth, right?
You've got these really thick coke bottle
glasses with like thick, black rooms.
Uh,
but he also had like long hair,
like down to the shoulders and like
black lipstick and my, Oh my God,
this is kitty. So weird.
I love it. And, and, um,
the neighborhood we grew up in was not
very alternative or like, you know,
so everybody was pretty much
the same. Very preppy. Uh,
like the weird one. You yes.
I'm like, he's weird. I'm gonna
follow him around at lunch, like,
like a little looser, like a stalker.
Right. And then, so one day he's like,
Hey Tina, have you heard of Marilyn
Manson? I'm like, who? She know,
I don't know what that is. So he let
me borrow his antichrist superstar CD,
because back in those days we
listened to cds. Good. So, yeah.
And I had a boombox in my room that we
got at a garage sale from the next door
neighbor, so nearby garage sale. Um,
and there's a CD player at the top and
I remember I would turn the volume all
the way down to like a little
bit pat like below one.
So like 0.9 volume and put my ear up
against the boombox is my parents.
I mean I wouldn't be here today,
I'd be dead if they heard that. So.
And I'd be like,
I'm so cool.
So that actually had a huge
impact on me because I,
I mean imagine coming from classical
music to, I guess that's like industrial,
it's not really metal but like
heavy industrial, dark music.
And I was just so off music and I was,
I was very fascinated by it.
I started like trying to like,
oh I found a clip. Sorry,
I'm going to go way off tangent
right now. Stop me. Okay.
So all these memories of pouring back.
So I found this clip on earrings,
like just like the clip, I'm part,
there was no actual earring, you know,
like the plastic part,
that kind of the metal plastic,
you know what I'm talking
about? Yeah. I'm like,
oh that would make a really cool nose
ring. Cause I want it to be cool,
but I didn't have any piercings.
So I would go to school,
I would run into the bathroom and clip
this like plastic clip on everything like
between like, like a bowl, you
know, on my nose. I'm so cool.
So anyway, so that Marilyn Manson and
then a few years later in high school,
my best friend, her name
is also Tina and she, uh,
she had a guns and roses tape.
Oh my gosh,
a cassette tape appetite for
destruction. So I heard that. Um,
and then the third musical
influence that I heard,
but I only heard the first two tracks
of their album was a daft punk CD that I
got at yet another garage sale. But it
was scratched up. So only the first,
it wasn't even first teacher at
first track and a half worked.
And so I would like listen to it for
like a track and a half and then it would
like skip and then stop working.
I rewind it and just keep listening to it.
And that was my musical influence
that in classical music.
So go and that actually makes sense.
It, if you follow Tina's career,
it makes sense because she's really all
over the place in a good way. You know,
she's not the typical cellist and
you know that you would go see, um,
at the Disney concert hall, you know,
like she does all of this school stuff.
Like I, one of the concerts
that I saw her at, um,
she ended up playing Super Mario brothers,
uh,
the theme and then all of a sudden went
into like a heavy metal version of it.
And I freaked out because I was like,
this is like,
it's like she's dedicating this to me.
Like I, it was, it was so big for you,
just for you. That's right. Uh,
and it was, and it was really
cool. So, you know, like,
uh, it, it's, it's, you have
these, she has albums out, right?
Like there's this one called game on
where you play a video game music.
So, how did that come about and, and,
and how do you as a musician, you know,
cause you,
do you,
do you do your own compositions and
arrangements for when you're doing a cover
and like, you know, putting
your own spin on it,
like how does that blend of
metal and classical come about?
Right, right. So this album
that she's talking about,
it was actually my first album.
I finally got signed to a major label
to Sony to almost two years ago.
So game on was the first label
released album that I did.
But actually previous to that I self
released nine albums. My myself,
I self funded it, I recorded it
myself, didn't know what I was doing,
but I figured it out along the way.
If you listen to like my oldest albums,
it's like, well that's
really bad, you know, and uh,
hopefully it gets a little bit better as
I'm figuring out what to do. Um, but I,
you know,
I released albums that
were fully classical and my
parents were happy about that.
And then I did some like super metal ones.
There's one called cello metal because
that's just how creative I am. Cello,
metal. Um, and then, uh,
so when I got signed to Sony was weird
timing because I had planned on doing a
music video, music video,
sorry, a gay music album.
And I've been,
since I moved to La,
I feel like everyone's in
the entertainment industry
in some way or another. Um,
so I started doing, when
I came to college, uh,
as like a side gate to make money
amongst other things, I try to sell Avon,
et cetera. Wasn't very good at that. Um,
but I started doing session work and
slowly I built that up and I s I ended up
playing on a lot of video game, like in
the actual soundtrack. So I had thought,
oh,
maybe I should do some versions of my own,
of the stuff that I've played on or
some of my favorite game music. Um,
and so when Sony sign me, they said, oh,
we were thinking that maybe you could
do like a video game music album. Like,
no way. Check out my spreadsheet
because I love Google spreadsheets.
So I already had a spreadsheet of all
the music I wanted to do, you know,
the tracks. Um, and so it was really one
of those situations where it was like,
perfect, perfect timing. Um,
and so I just kind of picked some of my
favorite music. Some of the games that I,
I did play a little bit and then some
just like epic music that I love,
like final fantasy seven. I mean
it's just like opulent music. Um,
so that's how that kind of came about.
So. Cool. Do you have
a favorite video game?
Um, it doesn't count. I don't
know if it counts as a video game,
but like what I'm playing right now,
it's just really bad.
I don't know if you guys play
home scapes or garden scapes. No.
Do you like what's that?
It's like my mom plays a two.
That's when you know it's bad.
I was like telling my mom, oh,
I found this thing of like gardens scapes.
Well me too.
I'm like, oh no, I'm like playing
the same games as my mom. Um,
it's kind of like little matching games
and then you can like win points and
like upgrade your garden.
I know.
Okay.
Not Men.
I would play it on iPad and your
iPhone and stuff. Oh, there you go.
We know we have to check it out or
promoting current scale now.
Um, so yeah, you mentioned you're a album,
cello medal and I mean you have songs
by like black Sabbath and Metallica
slayer. Like it's so, so good. It's these
are, these are not just covers, right?
Like there's like arrangements I'd go
into this that like did you end up,
you know, really getting into metal
and then it seems like sometimes,
correct me if I'm wrong,
but like when you're playing the
metal versions of songs like you,
you kind of treat the cello like a guitar.
Yeah, exactly. Exactly. So when I was
listening to that, guns and roses,
appetite for destruction, you
know, slash I was like, oh my God,
I want to be slashed. How
do I become slash so, um,
I think basically what I did with the
electric cello is just try to experiment
with it. I use, you know, guitar
effects. This is a pedal board metaphor,
a guitar player. But I thought
that's close enough. You know,
it's kind of in the same
range. And so, um, yeah, that's
exactly what I tried to do.
And even with the wonder woman
main theme, I sometimes, you know,
I would go on youtube and look at the
people just upload like the track and
there's some comments like, oh, the guitar
is cool. I'm like, it's not a guitar,
it's cello.
But,
but at the same time it's good because
I want it to sound like a guitar player.
So the fact that it's
a little bit confusing,
it's like both a good and a bad thing,
you know?
Yeah, no, then that's true. It's
actually, I, because I'm a Nerd, uh,
I've also corrected people
because there'll be like, oh yeah,
I love that little like Guitar
Solo in one room. And I'm like,
that is a challenge. What are
you talking about? Um, so, uh,
speaking of wonder woman,
um, that is such a cool,
that must be such a cool experience,
you know? Uh, tell us about that. Like,
what was it like to, to get involved,
first of all, with, uh, you know,
one of my favorite composers of all time,
which is Hans Zimmer, you know, and uh,
and then junkie XL that, that they made
this really cool iconic theme. Well,
you know, what was it like and how
did that process come about, uh,
to get involved, to be involved
in such an iconic movie? Okay.
Right. So, um, I think to, to backtrack,
the way that I met Hans was actually
through youtube. Um, and because my,
so my very, very first music
video I released it, oh my
gosh. Like 10 years ago,
I think. Yeah. I'm old. So 10, no, I'm
not that old, but 10 years ago, um,
it's called Queen Bee and it was my like,
metal version of flight of the Bumblebee.
I know it's been done before,
but you know, I was just starting, I was
not very original. But anyway, so, um,
I did a metal cover and he actually saw
the music video because he spends a lot
of time watching youtube videos,
like looking at musicians. Um,
and his office actually contacted
me. Um, and at the time I wasn't my,
I was trying to become
like a metal cellist might.
My life goal was to play with Rammstein
and like, that's what, and I thought like,
Oh,
if I like release this music video,
maybe like metal bands will see
the video and they'll be like, oh,
she should like, come play with us.
So that was my entire purpose. Um,
but instead that somehow accidentally
segues me into a career in soundtrack
work. So now, like the majority of my
work here in La, I work on, you know,
movie scores, TV scores, video game stuff.
Um, and so he saw the video called me.
I ended up, uh, the first movie that we
worked on together was Sherlock Holmes.
I'm the very first one. I remember I
walked in, I actually, I had this so bad.
If he watches us, please don't
get offended, Hon. Sorry. Um,
I actually didn't know who he was.
So when his assistant call,
like I'm calling from Hans Zimmer's
office, I'm like, who, what? Um,
so I went in,
I still didn't know what I was expecting
to his office in Santa Monica and
they're like,
oh,
Han's is having lunch in the next
building cause there's like all these
buildings. So I went up there
and I did recognize Guy Ritchie.
They were really having a having lunch.
And so I sat down and there's
like all these like, you know,
Cole celebrity people. And then
like me, I'm like, Oh wow, okay.
I guess I'm in a good situation. And so
that's how we started working together.
And then we worked on a bunch of, of
inception, a lot of movies after that. Um,
and so this one,
I think they had actually
been experimenting originally
they were thinking it'd
be a vocal, like a female vocal.
And for some reason, you know,
they tried different singers. Like it just
wasn't quite fitting. And the Han said,
oh, we should have Tina come in with
their electric cello and do some weird
shrieking sounds, you know,
like a screaming Amazon. Um,
and so I went in and that,
I mean,
it's a pretty,
it's like a simple melody that repeats
over and over and over. I must have,
I mean,
I literally played it like at least a
thousand times over and over and over,
but we finally figured it out. And the,
um, the theme is actually layered. It's,
it's not just one electric cello,
but it's like 30 layers of electric
cello to get that like really fat.
That's all you, yes. It's all me.
So yeah, lots of multi tracking. Um,
and actually junkie, I, I've
never even met him in person.
He wasn't actually there.
So it was just myself and Hans and then
all of Han's is people's entourage.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. So it was, but they both
compose the theme, right? I believe so.
Yeah.
There's a lot of times,
there's so many people working
on different components
of it, so, um, but yeah,
definitely.
That's so cool. I mean, I remember
the first time I heard that theme was,
I think it was Batman v Superman, the
movie. And there's that scene where, uh,
spoilers, a wonder woman basically saves
Batman because she actually has powers.
Um, no offense, Batman. I
love Batman too. Um, but um,
she basically does this and the music
comes on and you and I hear the cello and
I'm like, oh my God. Like this is
like my jam. I was so happy about it.
That's so cool. Yay. Um, and uh,
speaking of hands up, that's actually
one of the best concerts I've been to.
And I go to like 30 concerts
a year, like it's bad. Um,
and Tina was there and along with all
these other great studio musicians that,
that a Hans brought and they basically
just play his scores and that's,
that's was such a cool concert.
I mean it was,
they played everything from inception
to Sherlock Holmes. You guys played,
obviously you play wonder woman
parts of the Caribbean. Like,
what was that like and,
and what, you know,
was that kind of like a dream
of you to like, you know,
be on stage with the best musicians
in the world and like, you know, what,
what's that compared to
like, you know, what,
what you want to do in the
future or dreams of yours.
Right, right. So of course it was, I
don't know if you've guys have seen it.
It's on Netflix, like
the uh, live in Prague,
like our show that we did in prognosis
two tours ago, two years ago. Um,
but when Hans for said like,
oh,
we're thinking of maybe taking this on
the road instead of being locked up in a
dark room all day, you know,
writing music. And I thought,
great, because for me,
I love studio music, but while I'm still
young enough to prance around on stage,
I want to take the opportunity
to travel, to perform live. Um,
and so it was really, really
amazing. And we played mostly arenas,
which is crazy because we all thought
like, are, is anyone going to come?
Is it going to be like five people?
You know?
But it was amazing cause I mean Han's is
huge, so all over the world, you know,
the arenas are full. So it
was an amazing experience. Um,
and prior to that I actually in a past
life I was in the Cirque de Solei. Um,
and so it was weird to like
kind of revisit the same
arenas that we played. Um,
but with Hans this time and it was just,
yeah, I mean, I mean, what can I say?
It's really, really, really awesome
and there was good food I like,
I like free catering it. Okay. What,
wait, so you weren't certain display,
what would you do? I
well, I play the cello.
I was kind of like this weird like
you where like I look or bad. No,
I'm not that flexible.
No,
I was like a weird cello alien
and I was wearing this outfit.
I was skinnier then. I mean, I know
I'm not large now, but I had um,
they put me on a diet and they're like,
no,
I was the largest person in the
entire show. Like all these, like,
like acrobat girls with like eight packs
and wait to Jesus Christ. So I would,
I would actually paint on like fake abs.
So try to like blend in.
And I remember one time some,
some someone I think, uh,
waiting for us outside of the stage
shore and they saw me like, oh,
you're that jealous man, you are cut. I'm
like, it's makeup cause from far away,
like if you have really
bad like makeup on it,
it actually looks like you're super buff
and I have a one pack of like nothing,
you know, so, and the
acrobats are looking at me,
they were like working out all day and
I'm just eating in catering and I like
paint on my abs. Um, but yeah,
I was wearing this outfit,
it was all Swarovski crystal
and it was the Michael Jackson,
the immortal tour to slay.
So it was actually half owned
by the Jackson estate is,
well this was after Michael passed.
And so instead of,
obviously he couldn't do the tour,
so we had his vocals and then it was
combined with the circus late to add in
other elements.
And now they have the Michael Jackson
Jackson's show in Las Vegas and it's kind
of like the smaller version,
but the original one that opened
was also an arena tour. Um, so yeah,
I did that for two years.
I was a gypsy.
Crazy. You've done everything
and you're so young,
you would done everything
good for you. Um, so, uh,
you have a new album coming out this year
or you're working on this year right?
Fully. It'll come out this
year. I've only, we won't,
we're working on a song number two,
so we'll see how it progresses. Okay.
Can you tell us about, can you give us
a little bit of a preview for it or,
yeah, well I was like, I was
telling during an earlier,
like the idea for this album has
already changed like five times,
but that's part of the creative
process. You know, you,
you think you have a great idea and
then you do it and you're like, wow,
this is really horrible. And then
you erase it and you start again. Um,
so I think we have the general theme
down. Um, we're taking, it's not really,
I mean it's kind of a cover but
not really a cover cause we want,
I want it to do original material,
but being that I don't sing
and it's instrumental music,
it is difficult to have something that
grasp, you know, it's not radio friendly.
So we thought,
what if we took some classical pieces
but not an entire cover where you just
take a short segment like rappers,
they sample stuff that's recognizable
and then kind of like expand that,
explode that into something
original and different. Um,
so that's what we're working on.
So it's kind of,
I guess you would call it like
classically based cinematic mentally.
Of course they'll be some metal
elements. Yay. Just for you.
Um, and yeah, that's
what we're working on.
I'm hoping it'll come out around
the same time as wonder woman two.
That's like our hold a goal for,
for the timing.
Cool. Can you tell us anything about the
wonder woman music or no, no spoilers.
Contracts. I know. I got it.
I got it. Um, okay. So, um,
I wanted to ask about, um, you
know, you perform with Han's,
like are there collaborators that you
work with that just was, you know,
it was a very meaningful thing to you or,
or is there somebody that you dream of
working with in the future that you're
like, oh, I would die
if I work with, right,
yes.
So I remember how I said that,
that first music video that I made and
I spent every penny that I had on at the
time and I was like broke after,
um, uh, this metal music video.
I was hoping that Rammstein would see it.
I still really would love to work with
them. Um, but I don't want to read,
my thing is I don't want to, I never
reach out to people and say, Hey,
like I would've worked with you
because I tried to like, wait,
like manifest it and like,
hopefully eventually it'll somehow it'll
just come or we'll have like mutual
friends or something weird will happen.
Um,
so my dream is that one day I'll
be able to play with Rammstein, um,
hello rom sign,
but we'll send this to
him. Um, and then, um,
you were just a nom recently. Yes. Um,
and for those of you that don't know you,
if you could explain what that is,
but also, um, did you have, um,
Tina actually has an instrument line,
like, cause she does everything.
So can you talk a little
bit about that as well?
Yes. So in addition to music, uh,
I very actually very passionate about
entrepreneurship and investing in,
but that's a whole other thing that
we won't go into today. But one of my,
I guess it's side businesses,
uh, is a line of instruments, uh,
Bose and pickups for acoustic
string instruments. Um, so I,
I have a couple of different cello
models, classical cello models. Um,
we offer a Bose and both wood and
carbon fiber and like custom colors. Uh,
you could even get like the hair here.
This is actually horse hair,
but don't worry, no horses were harmed
in the making of any of these bows.
And we dye them like all
kinds of different colors. Um,
and so that's just something
that I also do on the side.
What's the difference between,
you know,
horsehair and other things that are other
types of hair that are used for both?
Usually yes.
On the Bose that I played
with the electric cello.
I actually try not to go too crazy
today because it's noon and a Monday,
so I don't want to be too extra.
But if I play really,
really hard and I use a normal bau,
I'll literally destroy like
one bow every 15 minutes maybe.
Because if you hit it really hard,
all the hairs will break.
And so for actually that cello,
when I play,
I usually use fishing wire because it's,
it's like plastic,
so it doesn't sound as good. But um,
it's, it lasts a lot longer again,
since the cost, like $80, usually
about 80 per rehire hair. Uh,
but for the classical cello, I do use
the traditional horse hair on the Bose.
Yeah.
And, um, I want to talk about the
difference between when, you know,
cause I actually grew up playing
the cello, this one, how, you know,
how did you transition to doing electric
and, and what do you think is, you know,
what were the challenges or what are
the difference or what's better or worse
between,
between both instruments?
Right, right. Um, I always
tell people the, um,
if you compare it to a classical
guitar and electric guitar, it's,
that's exactly the same. So yeah, I mean
you're, the frets are in the same place.
Uh, but as far as, obviously
when I play this cello,
I'm sitting and when I play
that at standing and it's
actually more difficult to
play the electric cello in tune because
your whole body, as you can see,
it's just one end pin.
So it's kind of like a tripod situation
where my legs are like this, right.
And that, and you're kind of like trying
to move with it so it doesn't fall over.
Because when I started it took me about
two years to figure out how to play it
without looking super awkward. I'm
sure. I still look awkward, but um,
cause there's not, there's,
there's some people,
there's a lot of people
who play electric violin.
There's some people who
play electric cello,
but it's still not a super
popular thing I guess.
So I was really trying to figure
out how to, how to do it, you know,
and to be able to stand so he can be a
little bit more mobile instead of just
sitting all the time.
If you're trying to hit the right notes
and you're playing like, you know,
and you're moving around
like how'd, yeah. And there's the
right now. Right, right, right.
And there's no frets. It's
muscle memory. So it genuinely,
it took me like two years of
nonstop practice on that one,
just to not sound
horrible. Yeah. So awesome.
Um, and so I mentioned I grew up playing
the cello. I haven't played in years.
So for somebody like
me, no, definitely not,
especially after she played. Um, so, uh,
for somebody like me
that is you or you know,
somebody that's a beginner that's hoping
to play or, you know, it like, for me,
it seems very daunting to get back
into this just because as you mentioned
earlier, there's like, you know, it
takes discipline and, and you know, what,
what would,
what advice would you give people like
me and beginner musicians that, or what,
what, you know, tips or what do you do
to not get uninspired and keep playing?
Right.
I think
everything's just about consistency.
And I'm not gonna lie and say, you know,
you're always going to want to practice.
I don't even want to practice sometimes,
you know, but I have like the
internal Asian tiger parents,
like already in my brain. So
even if I don't want to, I'm
like, I have to, you know,
like I have to. So, um, if you just
force yourself to be a consistent,
and I'm not saying eight hours a day,
cause we all have lives, you know,
and I don't do eight hours a day anymore.
Um,
but even if it's like a good 30 minutes,
like really focus 30 minutes
every day or an hour, um,
whether you're learning cello or anything
else, it does come pretty quickly,
but it's mostly about consistency,
you know. Yeah. Okay. We'll
suit, but thank you. Okay.
Um, so, um, we actually only have time
for one more question unfortunately.
Uh, but um, and then Tina is going
to perform one more song and uh,
and then I think of some good questions
cause we'll open up the floor to
audience questions. Um, so, uh,
I wanted to also ask about, um,
you had a lot of partnerships with
brands and that's interesting, you know,
for a musician like a, can you, can
you tell us about that? I think a,
you work with Bentley last year,
you're working with Ritz Carlton,
like what's that like and how do those
things happen? Like that's so cool.
Great. Thank you. Uh, definitely very
grateful for that. Um, and again, I don't,
I don't actually have, I don't reach
out. Usually. Not usually. I never,
I don't reach out to, to brands, you know,
I don't have someone pursuing it for me,
but,
so these happen organically,
which I think is the best
way for things to happen. Um,
and so the Bentley Partnership,
actually the marketing director,
Mike Sayer of Bentley in the UK,
he came to one of my shows and then for
some reason he liked Instagram messaged
me. But you know what, Instagram,
if we don't follow them,
it goes to your archived messages. So I
like didn't see his messages for months.
Right. And I think finally
he emailed me, he's like, oh,
like I tried to message you
but you ignored me. You know,
I'm a messaging you do the wrong way.
You should have given you a business card.
Like I did. No, he came to the show,
but then he didn't come like in person,
you know, he didn't leave a
card like, like she did. Um,
so anyway, we connected. Uh,
and then last year I did four
performances for Bentley.
I actually wrote the music, I scored
a commercial for them for the new Ben,
take a hybrid, which was their SUV hybrid
SUV, um, which works with idea of like,
you know, taking something
old and, uh, you know,
the Bentleys turning a hundred years old
this year. So it's a very old company.
So taking something that's old, like this
cello made an 1880 in Paris, France. Um,
and transforming it and
making it something modern
electric with the, you know,
with the hybrid SUV.
Um,
so we did that and that was
a great partnership for a
year. And then this year,
uh, I am a brand partner
with the Ritz Carlton. Um,
so I'll be visiting some of their
different resorts. I know, awful job, uh,
visiting the resorts and getting inspired
by, you know, the locations, experiences,
the food that we'll have there,
um,
and taking that and composing
like a kind of a soundtrack,
a theme song for each location. Um, and
so, yeah, and then playing a little bit,
a playing like a very short show
at each one. So I don't know,
I'm super excited about it. We have
a meeting on Wednesday, you know, to,
to plan the schedule for
this year. Cool. Man,
that sounds like a nice part of the job.
Yeah. Yeah, definitely. I love to travel.
I love to eat. I love to play
music. So cool. Oh, am I fancy?
Rambo gets to come to yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hopefully he doesn't get
in trouble at work though.
He's supposed to be at work
right now. Okay. Hi. Hi. Hi.
So first of all, thanks for coming out
and you know, thanks for having us. Oh,
of course. Thank you. That
was wonderful. Um, yeah,
I saw you're playing not just the cello,
but also the air. Whew. Yes. Uh Huh.
And I was just wondering if you had
some thoughts like how they compare and
contrast the spirit of the instrument.
Right. So the era, who was that? Um, you
know, the tall, thin, Chinese thing, um,
and it's made out of a
rosewood and snake skin. Um,
and I don't really know. I mean, there's
a, there's a fingerboard if you know,
so it's kind of similar to the cello,
but the strings are actually
suspended in the air.
I wish I brought one to show you guys.
So there's actually,
you're not actually pressing
against anything, so it's
just a string. Um, and it's,
I don't know. I don't really, I don't
know even know if I play it properly.
I'm self taught. So I, I, I
bought one. Um, actually, wait,
do we have time if I tell a really quick
story about how I learned to play the
air? Who, yes.
I was doing this concert with the Golden
State pops orchestra and they were
doing a video game, music concert
and I was already playing a g,
I don't know if you guys played
journey the no. Yeah. So I, yeah,
I asked him injury. So
I did the original, uh,
I play the Cello Solos for that game. And
so we were playing journey. It's like,
oh, Tina, since you're
playing in the concert,
you're going to be there
already and you're Chinese.
Do you play the Chinese air?
Who, you know, cause all Chinese people
played there. Who? Um, but I thought, oh,
like what is it? They're like, yeah, we
have this game and a features the air who,
and I thought, wow, another opportunity
to be featured on stage. Yeah,
I want to do that. I could wear
something Chinese. That'll be really fun.
But I had, I never played the
air who before? So I lied. I
lied. I lied. I said, yeah,
I could play the air.
Who is just,
if you could just send me the
music ahead of time. So I get,
and there was still like two weeks till
the concert, which is not that much time.
Um, and so I got off the
phone, got on Craig's list. So
searching air, who ere, who?
Nobody. There was no air hose for sale.
So I finally found a store in Texas,
in Austin, Texas. I had air who's
with like overnight shipping,
so I pay like $100 extra for shipping.
It arrived. I practiced every night.
I didn't sleep. I was like trying to
learn. I was watching youtube videos,
like how to play the air, who, um,
and I, I think I kind of did. Okay.
We use a lot of reverb, um, and the
concert and it was, it was pretty simple.
It wasn't a super complicated
part thing, thankfully. Um,
so that's how I play the air. Who,
so when you asked me about the air,
who I really am not educated on actually
what it's supposed to sound like. I'm,
it sounds very ethnic I guess cause
the tonality is different. Um,
but it's still like continuous
pitch and everything.
So I guess you had faith in yourself
because you knew like the principals
yes. The principles and you just
kind of slide around. If you miss it.
It's like I meant to do that as part of
the, it's part of the Chinese ness of it,
you know, it's like wow.
Right. Um, and it's, it is,
it is very forgiving them that
way. Yeah. Cool. Next question.
Um, do you have anything
else you can say about, uh,
working on journey with Austin? Like,
um, you know, what you think about, uh,
having such like,
evocative visuals to go with your
music and those kinds of things?
Yeah. So when we started working on
journey, I mean, it was so many years ago,
I met Austin through
USC, uh, at school. Um,
and we had no idea it was gonna turn
out to be such a success. You know,
it was the first video game every ever
nominated for best soundtrack for a
grammy. Um, but when we did it,
like he was still in his old studio,
which was literally, it was just
like a room and like, you know,
we were both just slumming it and
like trying to figure out what to do.
And so I had, we both had no idea that
would turn out to be such a big, um,
I guess a successful game. Um, and yeah,
I remember I just went to a studio
a few times. We will lay trial,
different ideas again, lots of reverb
and I saw some of the early visuals,
but it wasn't, it was much later that
it was actually placed into the game.
So yeah, it was fun. It was
great. And I still work with
Austin, so it's good. Yeah,
he just wrote to me a Instagram
messaged me right before I got up here.
So you don't have him blocked? Fortunately
we don't have him blocked. I don't,
I don't have him black. No, no. Isn't it?
Okay.
Oh, right here. Cheery.
Thanks. Uh, the effects of the wonder
woman soundtrack. I mean, I love that. Oh.
Um, made me think a little bit of
like Les Claypool or Tom Real, like,
I'm curious what it,
what it's like to learn the classical
style versus kind of try to push the
envelope of what an
instrument is capable of.
Like is there any overlap with some of
those artists or are you just out there
on your own?
Yeah, definitely. I mean, when I started
a, again, I, youtube was like my teachers.
So when I first got my electric
cello, I think it was about, yeah,
about 11 years ago when I was in college,
um,
I bought an electric cello with a
credit card, you know, from Yamaha. Uh,
and then I was like, okay,
how, what do I do with this?
So I would just go on Youtube and
watch guitar tutorials and try to like,
cause the tone,
the tonality again is very,
very different from a
classical instrument. Um,
and then also being able to
improvise because most of
us classical musicians, um,
are not taught to improvise.
You play exactly what you're told to
play and you play it the same way every
time. Right? So it's a, it was,
it was more of like a mental thing even
rather than a physical cause once you
wrap your head around, you
can do you want, you know,
you can express yourself to the music.
And then just learning some different
scale pat like scalar patterns and
passages, um, that you can use in
like your solos or whatnot. Uh,
and then just playing around with pedals.
I actually went full digital very,
very recently. This is from
a line six, but I used to,
I was like a big collector of
pedal, so like analog pedals. Um,
and I used to love those. But after
a while there's some feedback issues,
you know, and now with new technology,
um, this unit right here, uh, it's,
it's both the APP modeler. So instead of
having like a giant amplifier, you know,
being carried in here, um, I just,
everything is processed through this
little pedal board. So all the effects,
all this amp sounds, everything is in
there. So it's really, really convenient.
Yeah.
Uh, going off of that, uh,
is that basically you're like piece of
equipment you can't live without or do
you have something that you really, really
love that you take everyday? This is,
this is it now. Like before when I did
shows, oh my gosh, I had to hire like a,
you know,
a company cause these amps are so heavy.
And of course I like to be melodramatic.
I have lots of like different amps.
So they come in like with a big truck,
unload everything,
and then all my pedals and this or that.
And now this little thing on the floor,
you just put it in a backpack.
Uh, you know, I don't carry it.
My Fiance Rambo carries it, but still
it's easier. It's easier for me.
It's easier for him and he
likes it too. Right. Okay.
Good answer. Next question. Hi,
thanks very much for coming.
You're music is amazing. Thank you. Um,
I what you're talking about with what
you've been doing with the electric cello
reminds me a lot of, um, have
you ever heard of Ronald Yankees?
He's a keyboardist. Um, I've seen
some of his videos on youtube. Um,
but he has this one song that's called
guitar sounds that he's using a keyboard.
I actually thought the first time I heard
it that it was just entirely electric
guitar.
Right.
And I was so surprised when I learned
that it was actually a keyboard.
So it might be something interesting
for you to look into because he's doing
something similar. Is it with a keyboard
that you do with the electric cello and,
yeah, definitely. Yeah. We'll run.
We'll junkies. Yeah. Thank you. Yeah.
Maybe you can play with him and Ramstein
one day. Yeah, that'd be really cool.
Signs mine. I'm not sure how amazing
concert opportunity, but I don't, I mean,
you don't reach out to him, so
he would have to find, you. No,
know I check other artists out and stuff,
but it's usually for like people
that like, you know, I don't know.
I don't know what it is. I just feel like
energetically is that, is that wrong?
Should I be like, I just don't want
to be one of those people like, oh,
work with me please. I'll play cello for
you. Balance. There's a balance. You know,
I try to,
it's more of like dangling the carrot.
Like you could reach out to Ramstein
is all I'm saying. Hmm. Yeah.
But I'd be like heart, so embarrassing.
Heartbroken if they said no, thank you.
But then nine, but then they're
not cool. Okay. That's fine.
I'll give it five more years and then,
okay, next question. So, uh, speaking of,
um, metal, uh, what are
you listening to? Recently?
Not a lot of metal recently.
I have to be honest. So, uh,
recently I've been obsessed with
financial, a youtube videos.
I have them on a playlist and I listened
to them every, if I'm putting on makeup.
Uh, but as far as like metal, obviously
rom sign is like my big, uh, obsession,
obsession.
And I'm,
I'm more into like when you mentioned
earlier about my cello metal album,
more of the classic, uh, old school
metal. Like now I'm honestly,
I haven't heard a lot of like new, new
bands that I'm really, really into.
Huh? White Chapel. Yeah, the
white chapel is cool, you know,
but I'm like old school stuff, black
sabbath, Metallica and whatnot, but more,
more industrial metal for sure. Yeah,
it'd be so cool. Have you played with the,
like there's these newer bands, I don't
know if you were thinking about these,
but like behemoth and like, like a, you
know, sleep, like there's just like more,
you know,
newer bands that I think would love,
I'm going to hook you guys up with them.
Yeah. Okay. Yeah, it's going to happen
next.
Hi. Hello. So I'm a
pianist and a huge gamer.
And I remember reading on the Bio intro
that you also worked with League of
legends.
I'm kind of curious how that went.
Oh yeah. So I play, oh my
gosh, I forgot what year was,
I think it was three championships ago
when it was in la at the staple center.
Do you remember? I think
it was a few years ago. Um,
they just reached out and said,
uh, would you want to play for the,
for the championship? So we
opened it, uh, it was myself,
West Berlin from limp Bizkit.
Um,
and then the drummer from a combat
Christ who just left the band and then
crystal, crystal method and an
orchestra. So it was like this big,
like not a mess. So it was like
organized mess of just stuff. Um,
and yeah,
it was a lot of fun.
Okay.
And my brother was really,
my little brother,
he's a huge league of legends player,
Him and his wife.
So they were like totally geeking out.
And they,
I remember they gave us a gift bag and
there's just like stuffed animal thing
from, and then they're like, oh my
God, can I have it? I'm like, sure,
you can have it.
So they were happy about it.
I think they were more excited than I was.
You know,
you also have a god of war
music video coming out, right?
Actually, yeah. It just,
it came out I believe last month. Um,
so yeah, I did a cover of the God,
a god of war. I tried to play the game.
I'm not very good at it, but it's good.
But it's hard. Really hard.
Oh my goodness. But yes, the,
the video is out on youtube now. It's
really cool. You guys check it out.
Thank you.
But time for one more question.
Okay.
This smells good in here as,
yeah, there's that curry.
Is that it? We good? Okay.
Well thank you. Good. Well,
you guys, uh, it, can you tell,
can you tell people where they can find
you on the internets? Yeah. So Tina, whoa.
Gee, you, Oh, uh,
if you just go to [inaudible] dot com
that is my website and there's links to
everything I'm on, you know, the usual
Facebook, Instagram, Twitter, Youtube.
I don't need to tell you guys. If you
just Google it, you can write to me. Oh,
Google her. Right? Yeah. But thank you
so much for coming. That was so awesome.
Thank you.
Yeah.